the world is making adjustments
following a new and even more infectious
strain of the coronavirus spreading in
the united kingdom and beyond
it comes with nearly 80 million known
infections around the world
resulting in at least 1.7 million deaths
holly williams has more on the global
impact of the pandemic this morning
there were no crowds in the vatican
saint peter's square yesterday
when normally they gather in their tens
of thousands to hear the pope's
christmas blessing
no worshipers in notre dame cathedral in
paris
though they did broadcast this concert
recorded in the medieval structure
damaged by a fire last year
and here in london many people felt that
christmas had effectively been
cancelled as we saw earlier this week in
the city's commercial heart
the government says the country has
entered its worst recession
in 300 years this is oxford street
normally
the busiest shopping street in all of
europe as you can see
it is eerily quiet after a new mutated
version of the virus
was discovered here in the uk and london
went into strict lockdown
the authorities here said the new strain
was more infectious
a heartbreaking christmas for millions
of people mixing between
households including on christmas day
was banned
for christians queen elizabeth gave her
traditional christmas day message from
windsor castle
where she's social distancing in
splendor in the united kingdom
and around the world people have risen
magnificently to the challenges of the
year
but for thousands of truck drivers left
stranded on the roadside
when france closed its border to the uk
there wasn't much to celebrate
just frustration and anger
for christians this festival is a time
of hope
symbolized by the birth of the baby
jesus
and amongst the despair and the
loneliness there is
hope this christmas for billions of
people
of all faiths it comes in the form of a
vaccine
in the pope's christmas day address
yesterday to a small socially distanced
group
he called for international cooperation
by governments and businesses
to make sure that everyone gets access
to vaccines for covert 19
especially the most vulnerable and the
needy the pope said quote
we cannot erect walls all of us are in
the same boat
jerica holly williams thank you